when I was really worried about not
having a story for season two and it not
being as good as season one and being I
mean I was so I mean I honestly really
did try and like back out
and everyone was very supportive and
enthusiastic and also would really
listen to the fears of that and actually
I took a lot of inspiration from how
Godfather and like upped its game for
Godfather too I mean that sounds sort of
ludicrous but actually sometimes you
need to go so far away from the thing
you're making to um to get the most
perspective and inspiration on it
because if you're watching things that
are sort of similar the whole time then
you sort of feel a bit cornered by style
and so that was that's really that was
really helpful for me and it was Phoebe
exactly she she pointed out the
restaurant scene in Goodfellas with the
red light with the red lamp shed when
Joe Pesci almost freaks out there was
something dangerous and yet warm about
it it was a place you didn't mind
hanging around in for half an hour but
there was something going on in the
shadows